este barrio es uno de los más pobres de
la hora gran parte de la población es
analfabeta no tiene acceso a información
sobre la campaña de vacunación lanzada
en el país el pasado mes de febrero con
ayuda de voluntarios amar a william un
militante de la sociedad civil decidió
sensibilizar a los más necesitados
hay muchos rumores que circulan según
algunos habría un chip en la vacuna que
podría controlar a las personas
vacunadas recientemente surge otro que
las personas morían dos años después de
haber recibido la vacuna todo espacio le
damos la palabra a la profesora nuncio
quien responderá a sus preguntas
estos habitantes tienen pocas
oportunidades para reunirse con
profesionales de la salud y las
preguntas son numerosas muchas personas
dicen que la vacuna china es mala para
la salud
es falso esta vacuna funciona muy bien
fue probada científicamente de hecho mis
padres recibieron la vacuna china
quisiera saber si la vacuna es peligrosa
para las personas que son diabéticas y
cuya tasa de azúcar en la sangre es
elevada
no no no es peligrosa de hecho en la
cuba es muy peligrosa para las personas
diabéticas entonces deben vacunarse lo
más rápido posible
y toda la campaña gubernamental de
sensibilización para la vacunación se
hace vía twitter red social que las
clases populares no usan por lo tanto es
una presa fácil para los antiguos cunas
creo que el coronavirus terminará siendo
un problema solo para las comunidades
pobres porque no habrán sido vacunadas
las zonas pobres serán consideradas como
epicentros de kobe debemos hacer por lo
tanto todo lo necesario para que no
ocurra
antes lo queríamos vacunarnos toda mi
familia estaba en contra pero ahora
después de esta reunión estamos
convencidos de que hay que hacerlo
amaral illanes ofrece a los
participantes acompañarlos al centro de
vacunación más cercano para recibir la
primera dosis de vacuna un recorrido de
20 minutos en risa que estas mujeres no
sabrían hacer solas y que no pueden
pagar en el lugar el ambiente está
movido los agentes del centro están
desbordados las mujeres acompañadas por
amaral y jan esperan mientras que el
trata de obtener su vacunación
haciéndole frente a varios rechazos
esperan durante varias horas mientras
que las que recién llegan son atendidas
de inmediato el tono sube rápidamente
entre estas personas y los policías en
la entrada de los corredores que dan
acceso a las salas de vacunación
estoy esperando desde hace cinco o seis
horas estas personas ricas llegan y son
vacunadas inmediatamente hay personas
que están esperando desde hace seis
horas no pueden comportarse así es
ilegal
somos pobres y nos discriminan debido a
ello
es muy difícil para nosotros venir aquí
porque los centros de vacunación están
lejos de nuestros hogares somos pobres
no podemos gastarnos 50 rupias en
transporte de lo contrario cómo comemos
no le preocupa mos a nadie las personas
que conocen a otras importantes tienen
que amar a liliana no se rinde tras
varias conversaciones y cuatro horas de
espera la situación se desbloquea los
protegidos de militante la sociedad
civil son atendidos
primero debemos vencer la propaganda de
vacunas luego debemos crear una relación
de confianza con la gente y convencerlos
de que vengan al centro de vacunación
posteriormente debemos hacerle frente a
la mala gestión de los centros esa es la
realidad de la compañía celebra la clase
futura
cambio de paisaje en este centro de
vacunación de la capital pakistaní cada
día cerca de 7000 personas son vacunadas
aquí en un ambiente sereno
fue muy fácil muy rápido me tomo menos
de 5 minutos
los profesionales de la salud están
preocupados frente a las desigualdades
de la campaña de vacunación
y tengo la impresión de que la mayoría
de las personas vacunadas al día de hoy
son personas educadas privilegiadas no
son personas pobres y sin igualdad en la
vacunación así usted tenga al 20 o al 30
por ciento de la población vacunada no
se está protegiendo frente a una
epidemia las personas más vulnerables
estarán alrededor suyo a usted lo
contagiarán de nuevo las variantes que
aparecerán en los barrios pobres en
sam's la media en este barrio
desfavorecido de islamabad una gran
parte de la población no tiene derecho a
vacuna porque está en situación
irregular y un documento de identidad es
obligatorio para hacerse vacunar aquí la
mayoría de los habitantes como abdul
zahir son refugiados de afganistán
[Música]
andor es mi panadería 10 refugiados
afganos trabajan para mí todos tienen
papeles vencidos
más de un mes este es mi tarjeta de
refugiados se venció hace diez años
nadie se preocupa de nosotros somos
seres humanos no hay vacunación posible
para nosotros chewaka no se contagia
puede contagiar a otro el kobe no hace
diferencia entre paquistaníes y afganos
habría unos 3 millones de personas sin
documentos de identidad en pakistán
refugiados pero también ciudadanos
paquistaníes que nunca han adelantado
trámites administrativos